Trump EU Ambassador Gordon someone
revises his testimony in a big way
Republicans play defense and we analyzed
the results of last night's off-year
elections I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a VPN
yet visit expressvpn com /ban ok we have
a lot to get to on today's show we'll
get it we'll get to the amazing
incredible revelation surrounding the
Trump EU Ambassador Gordon some in just
a moment first we have to give you all
of the updates with regard to the off
year elections that happened last night
so Democrats are in a very celebrity
celebrity mood a celebratory mood and
they should be I mean last night was a
good night for Democrats it was and
Republicans can spin it as though it
wasn't a terrible night for Republicans
and in certain ways it was I guess ok if
you look at Kentucky for example the
Kentucky governor Matt Bevin who is
always an unpopular figure in Kentucky
remember he ran against Mitch McConnell
and the Senate primary just got
destroyed by McConnell a few years back
I think it was 2016 and then he ran for
Kentucky governor and he won well he was
a really really unpopular governor and
he lost very very narrowly to Andy
Beshear that's not a huge surprise a bit
of a surprise is not an enormous
surprise but it is a bad thing for
Republicans Virginia was much worse for
Republicans Virginia the entire state
has now turned blue the state
legislature in Virginia is now
completely run by Democrats it had
narrowly divided between Republicans and
Democrats before all of this has room
have Republicans feeling quite nervous
because if you're gonna take away one
message from the election results last
night it is that Republicans continue to
do fine in rural areas but if they
underperform at all in those rural areas
they are toast in the suburbs there's
experiencing significant losses and
those losses are in large part due to a
perception of the Republican Party that
is censored on President Trump and it's
just an unfortunate truth and I'll prove
this to you with some numbers in just a
second first let me explain what exactly
happened last night well according the
Washington Post a Democrats gained
control of both houses of the Virginia
General Assembly on Tuesday tapping
strength in the suburbs to consolidate
power for the first time in a generation
and deliberate deliberate abuse to
president Trump several results were
still closed after polls closed on the
most expensive and most watched Virginia
legislative races in years but Democrats
flipped at least two seats in the state
Senate and at least five in the house of
delegates to take majorities in both of
those houses officials reported
unusually high turnout in an election
that served as an opening salvo in next
year's presidential showdown a test of
democratic defiance and Republican
resolved in the
from now remember this should have been
a bad year for Democrats it should have
been named the economy is good the
governor of Virginia Ralph Northam was
caught up in a scandal in which he was
apparently either wearing blackface or a
KKK outfit one of the two in his medical
school yearbook from the 1980s and had
been caught on tape talking about the
killing of babies after they are born
and then the Lieutenant Governor had
been caught up in a sexual assault
scandal and then the third in line in
the in the Virginia chain of command had
been caught up in his own blackface
issue this was supposed to be a bad year
for Democrats it was not a bad year for
Democrats it was a very bad year for
Republicans in Virginia the sweep
completed its romantic political
conversion from red to blue of a
southern state on the Washington's
doorstep I'm old enough to remember when
Virginia was the very least a purple
state now it has moved blue both of
Virginia's US senators a majority of its
congressional delegation all three
statewide office holders are now
Democrats the state was carried by
Democrats in the past three presidential
elections Republicans have not won a
statewide contest in Virginia since 2009
the last Republican in the Northern
Virginia delegation delegate Tim Hugo
lost to Democrat Dan Helmer national
democratic organizations and interest
groups according to the Washington Post
carpeted the state with money boosting
suburban legislative races to the
spending level of congressional
elections they've been spending out the
wazoo particularly with regard to the
suburbs and of course Democratic
governor Ralph Northam is fine right he
is he is poised to be one of the most
consequential Virginia governors in
recent times according to the Washington
Post he promises to work with the new
Democratic majority to enact gun control
push forward LGBTQ agenda and fight
climate change
northern said Virginia is officially
blue which is interesting because his
face is officially white but apparently
it depends on sort of how decides to
dress that day Republicans who when
Trump was elected had a seemingly
insurmountable majority in the House of
Delegates lost footholds in several
suburban districts they struggled to
separate themselves from the unpopular
President ends take moderate positions
on gun control and a Medicaid expansion
after years of voting against them in
the General Assembly Terry McAuliffe
said they're not only losing Virginia
they're losing America he said I think
Donald Trump was humiliated tonight
Trump wasn't on the ballot this year
however his policy his lunacy was on the
ballot I think it energized Democrats
well clearly didn't get Republicans out
of the polls now to be fair to be fair
to Trump to give the the full story the
fact is
many of the legislators in Virginia
didn't want Trump anywhere nearby
because they said listen we don't want
Trump here he's just gonna drive out the
Democratic base we don't have enough of
a Trump base in Virginia drive our base
out so Trump can correctly say well I
didn't actually bring my weight to bear
in Virginia and that's one of the
reasons why they had a problem there now
I think that is unlikely I don't think
that if Trump had set foot in Northern
Virginia suddenly Republicans would be
winning sweeping victories in the
suburbs of Virginia with that said Trump
at least has that defense to offer right
I wasn't called upon I didn't enter so
how are you gonna blame me about all
this but it is true that from suburban
numbers have been consistently bad since
2016-2018 was a wipeout in the suburbs
for Republicans will give you more on
the results of the election in Virginia
plus the election in Kentucky and some
good news some sort of bright spots for
Republicans even though this was in fact
a very blue night for Democrats nearly
across the board we'll get to that in
just one second first when the founders
crafted the Constitution of the United
States the first thing they did was make
sacred the rights of the individual to
share ideas without limitation by the
government that's the First Amendment
the second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
that's the Second Amendment and that's
the reason I'm a gun owner because I
believe in the Second Amendment I
believe that our rights have to be
protected I also believe that you have
an innate right to self-defense that
pre-exists government so to the folks
over at Bravo company manufacturing
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility and building rifles is no
different starting in a garage by marine
vet more than two decades ago
Bravo company manufacturing BCM for
short built a professional-grade product
built to combat standards Bravo company
manufacturing is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer manufacture
life-saving equipment the people at BCM
assume that when a rifle leaves their
shop it will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier overseas
to learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm you can discover more
about their products special offers and
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm if you need more convincing find
out even more about PCM and the awesome
folks who run it over at youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA they really are
terrific terrific Americans and they
make great product go check them out
right now as I say Virginia shifts in a
significantly blue direction it was
supposed to be a bad year for Democrats
here as governor Ralph Northam of
Virginia explaining that none of his
scandals ended up mattering because
presumably Trump race and equity
something that I have fought for since
I've been in public office even
practicing it as a pediatrician you know
I've always been inclusive and we've
moved forward from that certainly race
and equity will continue to be a top
priority of mine but this this was about
a bigger picture yesterday and I would
also take the opportunity to thank
Virginians they stuck with me they
elected me to be their governor their
73rd governor they didn't turn their
backs on me they supported me they
appreciate what we've done what our
leadership has done and I think they
look forward to me continuing I do some
good work well it does show how cynical
these sort of cancel culture of left is
because if it's one of them they don't
get cancelled if it is a Republican of
course that person's career is basically
over meanwhile a cyclist who was fired
after flipping the bird at president
Trump's motorcade has now been elected
to local office in Virginia's bad night
in Virginia for Republicans Julie brisk
men whose one-handed salute according to
the AFP was captured in an AFP
photograph that went viral beat the
Republican incumbent to a seat on the
Loudoun County Board of Supervisors in
state elections that saw Trump's
Republican party suffer a series of
stinging defeats the single mother of
two teens lost her job as a marketing
analyst for a US government and military
subcontractor after the snapshot of her
gesture spread across media and the
Internet in 2017 but she then ran for
office she ran for local office on the
Democratic ticket and she celebrated her
victory in a tweet that linked to a copy
of the image and she said I'm so proud
that we were able to hashtag up flip
Loudon so exciting stuff for for the
Democrats over in Virginia
meanwhile over in Kentucky it was a bad
night for Matt Bevin as I mentioned
early on so Matt Bevin lost his
gubernatorial seat now again that's
really not on Trump okay this one this
was like in Virginia can say that sort
of on Trump because the suburbs didn't
come in for for Trump and they weren't
going to come in for Trump in Kentucky a
large part of this was on Matt Bevin
himself Matt Bevin was running a twenty
point person personal popularity deficit
as of like three weeks ago he was 20
points underwater for most of his tenure
he has been literally the most unpopular
governor in America to him losing is
really more on him than it is on Trump
Trump came in rallied the base and this
actually became a much closer election
than a lot of people expected it to be
maybe three or four weeks ago by the
time of the election because of Trump's
intervention Bevin was favored in the
odds to win by like two-to-one odds but
he ended up losing
anyway is that on Trump so the question
is sort of split on the one head it's
not on Trump right Trump got out the
base he did what he is supposed to do
and down ballot Republicans did fine so
it really was more about Matt Bevin than
it was about Republicans generally on
the other hand Bevin was the most Trumpy
of all the candidates who were on the
ballot in Kentucky he was the guy who's
the loudest he was the guy who's the
brashest he was the guy who really
hugged Trump the tightest and it didn't
pay off for him in the way that he was
supposed that it was supposed to so is
that Trump's fault or was it Trump
trying to save him that data is just
unclear according to the New York Times
Democrats in in Kentucky governor Matt
Bevin is deeply unpopular Republican
refused to concede the election to his
Democratic challenger Attorney General
Andy Beshear with a hundred percent of
the precincts counted Beshear was ahead
by approximately 50 100 votes Fisher
presented himself as the winner telling
supporters he expected Bevin to quote
honor the election that was held tonight
which is funny probably Bevin should
just walk around for the next several
years claiming that he's the actual
legitimate governor of Kentucky
you know like stacey abrams in georgia
Beshear said tonight voters in Kentucky
sent a message loud and clear for
everyone to hear it's a message that
says our elections don't have to be
about right versus left they're still
about right versus wrong now Beshear did
run on a moderate platform many of the
Democrats in Virginia were running on a
more moderate platform so this should be
a lesson to Democrats don't run as hard
left as you can just run against Trump
and be moderate and you'll probably do
okay particularly in the suburbs
Democrats at the national level are
taking the wrong lesson so everybody is
taking the wrong lesson I think as per
our usual arrangement Republicans are
gonna take from this we need more
cowbell
write more Trump and Democrats are gonna
take away this from this we need more
progressive leftism that is anti Trump
as opposed to more moderate candidates
like Beshear in Kentucky who was not
campaigning as a radical in the same way
that the 2020 Democratic presidential
candidates are Bevins troubles however
were not a drag on other Republicans
they captured every other statewide race
in Kentucky so Kentucky voters were not
really rejecting the Republican Party
per se they're rejecting Bevin
personally Daniel Cameron in a historic
win handily won the Attorney General's
race he became the first black black
Americans who claim the office when the
first Republican to do so in over 70
years that's a major victory for
Republicans there Republicans also
captured the governor's mansion in
Mississippi as lieutenant governor Tate
Reeves defeated Attorney General Jim
hood by about five percentage points in
an open seat race that illustrated the
enduring
service is amok ording to the new york
times I do love that they talk about the
quote unquote enduring conservatism of
the deep south deep south voted Democrat
routinely up until maybe the past 25
years the final governorship up for
grabs and these off year elections in
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards a
Democrat is facing re-election a week
from Saturday in New Jersey
Republicans were actually on the cusp of
their first legislative gains in nearly
a decade with final results still being
tallied late on Tuesday Republicans look
likely to pick up two seats in the
assembly and one in the Senate powered
powered largely by a surge along the
southern part of the state where Trump
won easily in 2016 despite Democrats
local advantage in Pennsylvania the news
was worse for Republicans Democrats are
poised to gain control of local
government in a bunch of suburban
Philadelphia counties that were
Republican stronghold so in other words
the red areas are getting redder the
blue areas are getting bluer and the
purple areas are getting bluer that is
sure that that's sort of the short
answer so what does that mean well again
a little bit of information here
suggests that this may be more about
president Trump's personality than
anything else right that if you're
hoping to win back the suburbs as a
Republican well you really need to be
focused in on is more policy more the
Democrats are radical more than agenda
stinks and less on personal loyalty to
Trump for example that doesn't mean that
you shouldn't back the president right
it does mean that Trump is not popular
in the suburbs and hanging him on his
coattails on the suburbs was a fail in
2018 it's likely to be a fail in 2020 as
well as Steve Kornacki who does the
national political correspondent for NBC
News and MSNBC he was analyzing some of
the numbers in Kentucky and what it
showed is that that Trump in 2016 one
about 68% of Boone County 60% of Kenton
County and 59% of Campbell County those
were Cincinnati suburb counties how
exactly did these various candidates
fare in those districts Bevin
underperformed Trump dramatically in
every one of those districts
underperformed him in radical terms the
other Republicans actually performed
basically the same as Trump some of them
even outperformed Trump in those in
those districts so it's also worthwhile
noting that in even more liberal
suburban areas there were some moves to
curb the extraordinarily
word slant of the Democratic Party
Daniel Horowitz points out a
conservative review that suburban voters
electing Democrats aren't actually all
that radical and he points to what just
happened in Tucson Tucson had a
proposition 205 which was an effort to
make the city of sanctuary for illegal
aliens it went down in flames last night
by a margin of seventy one percent to
twenty nine percent despite backing from
the ACLU and other special interest
groups Horowitz has despite Republicans
facing increasing problems in the
suburbs a trend highlighted last night
by the GOP slaughter in Virginia's state
and local elections it's clear much of
it is a backlash against Trump's
personality the gops dysfunction and
lack of vision and the absence of a bold
contrast highlighting the radical nature
of Democrats it's not Trump's perceived
policies that are getting rejected
I mean Tucson is a perfect example that
is a very very blue area it voted
overwhelmingly for Hillary Clinton yet
even in that area more than 70% of
voters said they did not want police
prevented from inquiring about
immigration status
so the criminals can be turned over to
the to ice core Wood says this is the
same reason why Montgomery County
Maryland after much scrutiny of its
sanctuary policies is beginning to
change its tune in Reverse sanctuary
policies despite being at County Hillary
won by 55 points Horowitz has the moral
of the story is that the GOP brand is
tarnished for reasons that have nothing
to do with the core agenda Democrats are
seeking to implement for example a
radical sheriff and prosecutor for
opposed dice won their respective races
in Prince William County Virginia but
did they really wouldn't because of
those views or is it they win them just
just order they wouldn't despite those
views because the GOP brand is so
incredibly damaged and that seems
correct that seems correct I mean he
points out that there are areas where
Republicans are are not seen as
off-putting and they're wildly popular
for example Florida Governor Ron de
santis who is governed in very
conservative
fashion has a 72 percent voter approval
rating today
and that numbers 82 percent among
Hispanics despite that he has a gret the
fact that he has aggressively pushed
anti sanctuary legislation and is
pushing mandatory e-verify as well
Washington State voters last night
rejected affirmative action Washington
state is about as dark blue as it gets
so this is the meanwhile in Texas by a
margin of 75 to 25 horowitz points out
voters passed a constitutional amendment
banning a state income tax a measure
that will now require 2/3 support in
both houses of the legislature to
even levy a 1% income tax so is that
really about the Republican agenda or
the Democratic agenda or is it about
personality foibles I mean it seems that
it's much more about personality labels
again a perfect example Daniel Cameron
the guy who historically just won the
Attorney General slot the the black
attorney-general Republican of the state
of Kentucky he said that he was willing
to work across the lines he said that he
has he has pledged his support to
conservative policies but he does not
appear to be a radical he's only 33
years old so he is a rising star for
sure you know the fact that that he wins
in very handy fashion suggests that
again personality matters an awful lot
matters an awful lot when it comes to
politics and it suggests that President
Trump is gonna have to minimize the
Trump enos of his campaign if he was if
he wishes to win a sweeping victory come
at 20:20 I'll give you some more
evidence of this from Pennsylvania in
just one second first I'll tell you
about this brand new thing I've got in
my house it really is fantastic so there
is this brand new portrait painted
portrait that we have over our enormous
fireplace in our entry way that is it's
a portrait of my family me and my wife
and our two kids we have a third on the
way but not born hit so not in the
portrait it's beautifully painted it
really looks great and here's the thing
did I spend a bunch of money in order to
achieve this as I'm Richie Rich or did I
just spend a minimal amount of money to
get an amazing piece of art that now
hangs in our house and the answer is the
latter because if paint your life if you
want to give a truly meaningful gift you
got to try paint your life calm it
really is fantastic if you have an
original painting of yourself your kids
family a special place a cherished pet
at a price you can afford
from paint your life calm it's a true
painting it's actually done by hand by a
world-class artist created from your
very favorite photo it makes a perfect
gift for birthdays and anniversaries and
makes great decor for your house it's a
work of art I mean it really is and they
make it really easy like they'll
actually send you a photo of the of the
portrait and then if you don't like how
the portrait is turning out then you can
correct it and if it turns out that you
don't actually like it then you don't
have to take it it really is incredible
right now is a limited time offer I get
30% off your painting that is right 30%
off and free shipping to get this
special offer
text the word been to 64,000 again text
my name been to 64,000 when you support
our show you support our sponsors and
you're really gonna want to get involved
it's really really cool makes a
fantastic fantastic gift I got no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded completely text
my name Ben into sixty four thousand and
make this the gift for the holiday
season for Thanksgiving it makes
fantastic family if go check it out
right now
text Ben's sixty four thousand paint
your life calm truly a very very cool
company okay meanwhile in Pennsylvania
again bad night for the Republicans
according to the Philadelphia Inquirer
LT Pennsylvania voter unrest with
President Trump and the Republican Party
has taken over help deliver victories
for Democrats in Kentucky where they
narrowly took the governorship in
Virginia where they seize complete
control of the state the political
forces that shaped last year's midterm
elections showed no signs of abating
Tuesday voters turned on Republicans and
establishment Democrats alike in races
from Philadelphia and Scranton to the
suburbs of Delaware and Chester counties
locally Democrats will now hold all five
seats on the Delaware County Council a
Republican stronghold since the Civil
War they also assumed a majority on the
legislative body in Chester County in
Bucks County Democrats captured the
Board of Commissioners for the first
time since 1983 now again to be fair to
President Trump it is possible that
because his name is not on the ballot a
lot of his voters didn't get out I said
it's a local election he's not on the
ballot I'm not showing up and Democrats
continue to be extremely excited about
voting because Trump isn't on the ballot
until he's on the ballot and the only
way they can take their revenge is to
get out and vote today so maybe these
numbers uptick once Trump is on the
ballot however we've been we've I'm we I
mean conservatives Republicans have been
significantly underperforming in the
suburbs since 2018 and that should be
scary it should be scary for Republicans
going into the 2020 election which means
less cowbell guys yeah I know this is an
unpopular view in the Republican Party
the fact is less cowbell is the answer
here hey the shouting the tweeting we
may love it in a base maybe people in
the base may enjoy it and every so often
president from really hits the nail on
the head and it's fantastic I've praised
him when he's done that but overall
Trump is alienating the very voters whom
he needs to bring him victory in the
suburbs and he needs to help revive the
state level support for him now again a
lot of people are gonna say well you
know Barack Obama lost a bunch of state
seats also during his during his
election campaign right in 2010
Republicans swamped him in 2014 again
bad year for Democrats when that's true
off-year elections are usually bad for
the party and
the problem is that the that these may
be permanent we're not going to know the
answers whether these are permanent
shifts if this is shifting the country
in a permanent direction until President
Trump is actually on the ballot again
right it's in in 2012 I mean the
forecast was that Barack Obama was in
some trouble given how many seats he had
lost across the country and then he won
in 2012 in large part because he ran a
very strong and a very concerted
campaign he had media support behind him
who's running against Mitt Romney who
refused to attack him in a variety of
ways Trump is not gonna benefit from
from any of those systemic advantages
plus Barack Obama had won an
overwhelming victory in 2008 and he
actually lost votes from 2008 to 2012
right his margin of victory was much
smaller in 2012 than it was in 2008
Trump can't afford to lose even one vote
anywhere in the country so he can't
afford to - like it did this did have a
drag effect on Barack Obama in 2012 it's
just that he was so far ahead in 2008
that the drag effect didn't drag him
underwater Trump loses like five votes
and he's out of office so that means
that something has to fundamentally
change for Republicans it really does
okay well speaking of all of that this
brings us to impeachment gate 2019 so
the great benefit that President Trump
has in 2020 that doesn't appear on the
ballot in any of these off your
elections is the fact that Democrats are
going to be on the ballot and those
Democrats are insanely radical that
these Democrats are not popular again I
think Democrats can easily take the
wrong lesson from the elections of
2018-2019 they can easily veer off into
a radical direction and that's gonna be
a major major mistake you know who's
actually saying that today is Joe Biden
which makes sense because he's the one
who's saying listen I'm default Democrat
right just just do it for me right I am
default Democrat and pretending that you
can elect some sort of radical and that
that person is going to sweep to victory
is insane Joe Biden put out a statement
yesterday about this attacking Elizabeth
Warren directly he says the other day I
was accused by one of my opponents of
running in the wrong primary pretty
amazing on one level it's kind of funny
I fought for the Democratic Party my
whole career I know what we stand for
who we stand with what we believe and
it's not just policies or issues it's in
my bones
that's not something everyone in this
primary can say but at another level
these kind of attacks are a serious
problem
they reflect an angry unyielding
viewpoint that has crept into our
politics if someone does
agree with you it's not just that you
disagree that person must be a coward or
corrupt or a small thinker okay there's
a direct attack on Elizabeth Warren who
has been saying that you have to dream
big and campaign big Biden says some
call it the my way or the highway
approach to politics but it's worse than
that it's condescending to millions of
Democrats who have a different view it's
representative of an elite ISM that
working and middle-class people do not
share we know best
you know nothing if only you were as
smart as I am you would agree with me
this is no way to get anything done this
is no way to bring the country together
this is no way for this party to beat
Donald Trump he says there are a lot of
ways to fix our health care system and
to make our tax system fair to address
the challenge of climate change
I believe I've proposed the most
progressive transformational ideas in
the campaign and I can get them done and
he talked about all of his various plans
he says I learned a long time ago if you
question someone's motivations rather
than your judgment you get then their
judgment you get nowhere it's hard to
get pasco if you start off by saying the
other person is in the pocket of special
interest or is corrupt that's the way
democracy works he says he stands with
the Democratic Party of Barack Obama and
the Democratic Party of Nancy Pelosi and
he basically attacks Elizabeth Warren is
too radical and he is correct about that
he is correct about that and that's
Trump's big advantage is that if
Democrats take the wrong listen and run
a radical campaign from could easily won
but Trump would actually have to make a
campaign about the Democrats radicalism
now as we'll see the Democrats are
incredibly vulnerable on the score which
is why they're focusing in as I've been
saying now for weeks on impeachment
centrally make Trump the issue Trump
loses make democratic policies the
issues Democrats lose okay we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about your sleeve quality so
the fact is that every night you
probably climb on this spring mattress
the inherited from a relative and it's
just creaking and it's awful and you
wake up in the morning you're backwards
well you are a unique human being why
wouldn't you have a mattress that is
made just for you why would you buy a
generic mattress built for just some
other Rando helix sleep has built to
sleep quiz it takes two minutes to
complete they use the answers to match
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress whether you're a
side sleeper or a hot sleeper with you
like a plush or firm bed with helix
there's no more guessing no more
compromising on an average mattress go
to Hewett sleep calm /a Pierrot take
there two minutes liebe quiz they will
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life
helix sleep was even awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2019
by GQ and Wired magazine they have a
10-year warranty you get to try your
mattress out for a hundred nights at
risk free shipping
completely freed they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will right now helix is offering up to
125 bucks off all mattress orders get up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep calm
slash Shapiro again that's helix sleep
calm slash up rile by helix sleep
mattress my kids been waking me up at
four in the morning the good news is at
least the sleep I'm getting is quality
sleep because if helix sleep I am
desperate for it go check it out at
helix sleep comm slash Shapiro that's
helix sleep comm slash Shapiro okay so
speaking of the radicalism of Elizabeth
Warren I just have to bring you this
hilarious and ironic and wonderful story
about Senator Warren
so Elizabeth Warren is now very very
angry at Twitter why I mean what we told
five seconds ago that she's very happy
with Twitter because Twitter banned
political ads right the entire left was
celebrating Jack Dorsey hero of the
Republic because Jack Dorsey had banned
political ads he said we don't have the
power to fact-check
political ads so we're just not gonna
have political ads are just gonna ban
them then they said at the time that's a
crackdown on basic free speech notions
anybody should be able to run any ad
that they want and then we can fact
check those ads and we can point out
that they're wrong they're stupid in
fact if you had the policy that every ad
had to be fact check half of the most
half of the most effective political ads
in American history would never have run
right the Daisy out of 1964 which is
complete crap that Barry Goldwater was
gonna get us into nuclear war never
would have run hey the the the ad that
came from the anti Mitt Romney super PAC
in 2000 in 2012 all about how Romney
gave some lady cancer right that that ad
never would have run it got fact-checked
anyway right all of these ads it's good
to have more speech more speeches better
speech but Elizabeth Warren doesn't
believe that so she wanted Twitter to
shut this all down until it turns out it
hit her speech so this is a perfect is a
perfect hilarious wonderful example of
Elizabeth Warren learning the lesson of
the monkey paw the monkey's paw if
you've ever read that short stories
about a guy who gets three wishes and
then every one of his wishes ends up
with precisely the opposite result of
what he wanted because he did not
specifically say what he wanted
Elizabeth Warren really took a shot in
the grill here from Twitter
Elizabeth Warren is proving to be an
equal opportunist when it comes to
taking on social media company says CNBC
I love that spin so Lizabeth Warren
calls for Twitter to ban political ads
and then they do and then she's like but
they banned the ads I like and then CNBC
says she's an equal opportunist she's
willing to attack anyone mm-hmm or if
she's just the flaming
hypocrite on Tuesday Warren who's
running for president slammed Twitter's
new ad policy that bans political ads
which is weird since she's been ripping
on Facebook suggesting they should ban
political ads in the series of tweets on
Tuesday the Massachusetts Democrat
attacked the company for blocking
organizations that are fighting climate
change from running ads on the social
network while allowing ads from
companies like Exxon on the same topic
oh you mean that when you ban political
ads you end up banning ads that you like
Elizabeth Warren who could have
predicted such a thing aside from every
sentient human being with a working
prefrontal cortex who could have
possibly imagined that something like
this would happen
her criticism comes a week after Twitter
said it would no longer allow ads on its
service a policy that blocks ads from
politicians ads that refer to an
election or candidate or ads related to
politically sensitive issues Twitter CEO
Jack Dorsey then responded to Warren
with a tweet basically kowtow into her
he said we haven't announced our new
rules yet they come out November 15th
taking all this into consideration he's
like please leave me alone stuck more
more beatings sir please more beatings
the media is playing this as Elizabeth
Warren being mad at big tech no this is
Elizabeth Warren wanting a different
standard for her and her favorite causes
then she wants for everybody else in
other words she doesn't want Trump to be
able to run ads but she wants to be able
to run ads she doesn't want X town to be
able to run ads but she does want her
favorite climate change activists to be
able to run ads it's pretty hilarious
and pretty wonderful and she deserves
every bit of the blowback that she is
going to get over all of this okay so
with the Democrats and and by the way
Pete blew de jedge is is slamming Warren
it is good for him right he's
campaigning as a moderate people think
he's cutting into Biden's numbers that's
not really obvious it seems more that
he's actually cutting into Warren's and
Sanders his numbers because Biden is not
actually fading in the national polling
who to judge is just rising in the
national polling people who to judge
went after Elizabeth Warren yesterday
again it's not the only issue but it's
certainly a major issue I get questions
about it everywhere I go and what I'm
hearing from Iowans and from voters
across the country is there really is a
desire to do much more to build way past
what we were able to do with the
Affordable Care Act but people also want
to be able to make their own decision on
whether to leave their private plan or
not okay so Buddha judge again getting a
bit of a boost from from attacking
Elizabeth Warren and and look the entire
American business establishment is
afraid of Elizabeth Warren for good
reason
she does demonize success because she
does see America's successful businesses
as targets for her rapacious tax schemes
so Jamie Dimon who is the JPMorgan
chairman and CEO he launched into
Elizabeth Warren yesterday saying that
she vilified successful people which of
course is true we have to ask her what
she really means uses some pretty harsh
words you know some would say vilifies
successful people so that I don't like
vilifying anybody I know I think we
should applaud successful people and a
lot of people come to the company for
opportunity and choice and success we
want that for everybody
that now that's a little bit different
than paying your fair share and how the
taxation system should work that I
completely understand you know
successful companies have lifted up
society it doesn't mean they can't do
more it doesn't mean they didn't make
mistakes but so I think we should
applaud that and if you know people are
very specific things that we should do
different then we should think about
doing them different ok so again these
Democratic candidates are vulnerable on
a variety of scores because they're
learning they have taken too much away
from these state and local elections
over the past few years they think that
animus for Trump means that people are
willing to embrace the most radical
policies at the national level and that
simply isn't true but the the smarter
Democrats are saying okay well that
means that we really should be doing is
not focusing on our policies which kind
of suck and nobody likes instead we
should focus in on Trump and that's why
impeachment gate matters to the
Democrats that's the real reason why
impeachment gate is a thing now what
that means is that impeachment gate is
gonna be front and center for months
here at a time okay this thing is not
gonna stop the Democrats are not gonna
do this fast and dirty they're not
everybody keeps saying the Democrats
gonna speed this thing through there is
no reason for them to speed this thing
through instead they are now going to
drag this out they're gonna subpoena
everybody right originally they said
they were gonna get this done by late
October was the original estimate now
there's estimates they may get it done
by Thanksgiving unlikely unlikely my
guess is that they probably bring it
over into the new year why because they
think that the publicity is bad for
Trump and that is exacerbated by the
fact that team Trump doesn't have any
good defenses right their defenses that
they've that they've put out there so
far are really kind of garbage
because they refuse to embrace the only
defense that actually makes any sense
the only defense that is actually true
which is always the best defense we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that at this
time of year it's open enrollment season
so you're probably looking at all your
various insurances that you can get
through your company and one of those
insurances is presumably life insurance
there's only one problem life insurance
you get through your company it's
probably one tenth of what you actually
need so you should be looking for a
private life insurance plan as well I
mean this is a responsible thing to do
as a responsible adult this is where
policy genius can help policy genius is
the easy way to shop for a life
insurance plan that is not tied to your
job in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape the life insurance you buy
through policy genius stays with you
even if you leave your job policy genius
doesn't just make it easy to get life
insurance they can also help you find
the right home and auto insurance and
disability insurance - it really does
make it super easy that the app is
beautifully laid out when you're looking
at your workplace benefits this month
make sure to double check those life
insurance options and then check out
policy genius coms get quotes and apply
in minutes policy genius is your
one-stop shop for all sorts of insurance
go check them out right now policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance why not shop
competitively get the best price in the
best policy policy genius.com go check
them out right now ok we're gonna get to
the big breaking news an impeachment
Gaye 2019 in just moments but first if
you're not already a subscriber you are
missing out head on over to daily wire
comm slash subscribe for as little as
ten bucks a month you get our articles
and free access to all of our live
broadcasts our full library select bonus
content our exclusive daily wire app
which is pretty fantastic if you haven't
checked it out yet I mean the fact is
that the app is just it I mean really we
invested serious kuan in the app and it
looks great and you get to interact with
us if you choose the new All Access plan
you get all of that plus the legendary
leftist here's tumblr and our brand-new
ask me anything style discussion feature
that allows you to engage our hosts
writers and special guests on a weekly
basis and a couple of them already it
actually is a blast stop depriving
yourself come join the fun especially
because when you help us out you're
helping to insulate us from the left
that wants to deep platform everybody it
doesn't like we'll get to that in just a
little bit but come help us out come
join the team we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
you
okay so let's get to the latest breaking
news in impeachment a 20-19 and the
Republican defenses to it so as I say
this 2020 race Democrats think the Trump
is vulnerable because Trump is Trump and
that is the truth but if they run on
their own platform they're gonna lose so
instead what they're gonna do is they're
gonna run on Trump is the worst
and that's why impeachment 8 is really
more about election 2020 than it is
about impeaching Trump right now right
the chances that the Senate is going to
actually get rid of Trump are incredibly
incredibly low Mitch McConnell basically
said this yesterday said listen the
Democrats are not getting the process
right nobody's gonna vote for this thing
this whole effort is going nowhere I'm
not gonna start commenting on all of
these episodes that occur on a daily
basis
that are unfolding over in the house but
to say it it seems to me they still are
not providing the same kind of basic due
process rights that were provided both
Richard Nixon and Bill Clinton they
can't even get the process right so
beyond that we'll wait until we get it
here it looks to me like they're
hell-bent to do it and that we will end
up in an impeachment trial at some point
okay so yeah again I think that the
Democrats are doing this for political
reasons but every bad headline is
another brick in the wall they're
building against President Trump so the
latest bad headline for the Trump team
is is Gordon Sunland who is Trump's EU
ambassador who basically look the
ambassador of positions are basically
cush patronage jobs that you get for
being an ally with the president that's
not unique to Trump it's it was true for
Obama to basically you give a lot of
money and you end up is like ambassador
to Morocco right it's kind of sort of
pick which country you wish to live in
for the next four years and hang out and
for the next four years
they actually put real political experts
in some of these positions but a lot of
them it's like you're the ambassador to
the EU you get to live in Brussels and
hang out and Europe all the time seems
kind of Awesome that's what happened in
Gordon someone gave a bunch of money to
the Trump campaign and then he ends up
with no experience being the EU
ambassador and gets roped into this
thing where he is now worried about
having committed perjury in front of
Congress so yesterday he revised his
testimony he had testified before that
he did not think there was a quid pro
quo that went on between the Trump
administration and the Ukrainian
government for Ukraine to pursue
investigations into a variety of topics
including the 2016 elections Purisima
and Hunter and Joe Biden
Gordon something came back yesterday and
he revised his testimony so according to
the Washington Post in a significant
revision to his testimony the US
ambassador to the EU Gordon Sunland now
says he told the Ukrainian official and
security assistance to the country would
likely it would be likely to resume only
if the authorities in Kiev opened
investigations requested by President
Trump that could be damaging to former
Vice President Joe Biden in a
supplemental declaration
sunlen wrote I now recall speaking
individually with the Ukrainian
individual and in that conversation
saying that resumption of US aid would
likely not occur until Ukraine provided
the public Anti Corruption statement
that we had been discussing for many
weeks so he suddenly remembers all of
this happening sunland's new statement
adds to testimony by other national
security officials that described an
effort directed by Trump and personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani to link nearly
400 million dollars in security
assistance to investigations that could
politically benefit president Trump
Sunland a Trump donor turned diplomat
had been seen as a loyalist and he had
said originally that Trump was just
trying to combat corruption he had a
certain a previously released text
message that Trump didn't seek quid pro
quos of any kind someone said well no
that was just me quoting Trump and he
said that was me quoting Trump really I
think it was kind of a quid pro quo now
the White House released a statement on
this they said that the transcripts of
someone's new testimony show there's
even less evidence for this illegitimate
impeachment Sham than previously thought
White House press secretary Stephane
Grisham says quote ambassador Sunland
squarely states he did not know and
still does not know when why or by whom
the aide was suspended
he said he presumed there was a link to
the aide but cannot identify any solid
source for that assumption so the White
House continues to trot out a defense
saying there was no quid pro quo the
problem is saying there was no quid pro
quo is now in direct contravention of
testimony from ambassador Sunland kurt
volker the special envoy Bill Taylor the
charged affair in Ukraine Maria vanovech
the Ambassador to Ukraine and there's a
widespread perception inside the State
Department and virtually throughout the
diplomatic corps that there was a quid
pro quo that happened between the White
House and Ukraine and Trump keeps saying
there was no there was no quid pro quo
you know I could say there was a quid
pro quo and the quid pro quo was fine
but I'm gonna say there's no quid pro
quo the problem is that's a bad defense
tactic because the fact is it's pretty
obvious from the transcript and it's
also pretty obvious now from everybody's
testimony that there was in fact some
sort of quid pro quo
going on the question as always was
going to be was the quid pro quo illegal
now it could be based on false
information the quid pro quo it could be
based on the president receiving bad
information from rajul eonni and people
feeding bad information to Rudy Giuliani
and it could still be not impeach more
it could be dumb it could be bad policy
that is not the same thing as he
committed a crime this is the
president's final defense I've been
saying this for literally weeks I'm not
the only one Andy McCarthy who's been
very Pro Trump throughout the
administration Andy McCarthy the the
lawyer who writes over at National
Review former special prosecutor former
prosecutor at the the Southern District
of New York he said also you know the
relying on this no quid pro quo defense
is a fool's errand what Trump should
just say is okay yes of course I was
pressuring Ukraine I was pressuring
Ukraine for legitimate investigation
since what happened in 2016 and that
includes any sort of corruption that
occurred in Ukraine with regard to
hunter Biden and frankly that would be a
basically fine argument it's hard it's
very very difficult to prove intent
right the fact is that then the
Democrats would have to prove not that a
quid pro quo happened but that the
intent for the quid pro quo was to get
Biden looking forward to 2020 as opposed
to looking into everything Trump
associated with corruption circa 2016
that's hard to prove it really is
difficult to prove and the facts that
the the White House refuses to rely on
that defense is supremely bizarre it's
really really weird instead you end up
with weird defenses like this from
Lindsey Graham I mean Lindsey Graham
just looks like a shill now because he
won't say the obvious right Lindsey
Graham the senator from South Carolina
here he is yesterday saying I'm not even
going to I'm not gonna read the
transcript right apparently he there's a
reporter who tweeted out a reporter do
you plan on reading these transcripts
that were released Graham no and the
reporter asked why I said because a sham
process okay that just sounds like you
have no defense right that sounds like
you are you are covering your eyes and
your ears and pretending that you don't
know what's going on but we all know
sort of what was going on the fact is
again that there is an actual response
to all of this it is the response that I
have been laying out for weeks at this
point and by the way there's also a good
response that says yeah of course we
asked Ukraine to investigate hunter
Biden because there's some pretty good
information that hunter Biden was
involved in something nefarious at
Morrissey reporting over at hot air
quote
does the appearance of hunter Biden's
name in State Department email traffic
show corrupt influence on US policy
emails dug up by John Solomon in his
reporting on influence peddling then and
now suggest that the timing of Joe
Biden's infamous intervention in Ukraine
might be even more suspect than it has
looked before
Biden insists nay brag that he
threatened to withhold a mil a billion
dollars in aid in March 2016 almost
Petro poroshenko fired prosecutor
general viktor Shokan Biden claims he
did that because Shokan had not
aggressively prosecuted corruption
including that of Purisima however the
new emails show that hunters name was
being tossed around the State Department
a month earlier has the firm pled that
Chokin with being too tough according to
Solomon's reporting during that February
2016 contact a US Representative for
Purisima Holdings sought a meeting with
Under Secretary of State Catherine
Novelli to discuss ending the corruption
allegations against the Ukrainian firm
where hunter Biden worked as a board
member
according to memos obtained under a FOIA
lawsuit just three weeks before buries
mosz overture to state ukrainian
authorities raided the home of the
oligarch who owned the gas room and
employed hunter Biden a signal the
long-running corruption probe was
escalating in the middle of the u.s.
presidential election hunter Biden's
name in fact was specifically invoked by
the verismo representative as a reason
the State Department should help
according to a series of email exchanges
among US officials trying to arrange the
meeting the subject line for the email
exchanges read simply Purisima according
to Ed Morrissey at hot air the email
shows that the meeting was for the
purpose of getting Ukraine to back off
on its corruption probe of Brie's m'a
the email argued the Purisima had been
unfairly targeted by Shokan without
evidence and outside of due process it
also noted very pointedly the two
high-profile US citizens work with
Purisima and named hunter Biden
explicitly as Morrissey points out he
says that last sentence sounds like the
meeting was a fait accompli
as well it might since it concerned the
VP's son however whether and when the
meeting took place has not been
established but clearly state was
informed that Hunter's name was in play
and the Purisima was unhappy with Shokan
this was no low-level contact either the
people involved were senior officials in
the Obama administration that discussion
took place February 24th 2016 exactly
one week later hunter Biden's business
partner and fellow Purisima board
members Vaughn Archer dropped by to see
Secretary of State John Kerry at the
State Department's of C Street offices
Archer was no college roommate of Kerry
stepson so it could have been a
coincidence but it's never been explored
less than a month later Biden once
Ukrainians banded Shogun's
firing
so that's that looks kind of bad right I
mean that this is what Ed Morris he is
saying says that certainly looks like
the kind of corruption of which the
House Democrats are accusing Donald
Trump does it not at the very least
these emails undermine the idea that
shokhin wasn't being tough enough I'm
burries MA and that no one in the Obama
administration connected the dots
between hunter Biden his dad and
Purisima it stinks of corruption into
and interference for personal or
familial gain although one needn't goat
it didn't need to go to Ukraine to find
evidence for it okay so in other words
Trump has a pretty solid defense here I
was targeting corruption I was
suspicious of corruption the reason I
was suspicious of corruption is because
it there might have been corruption and
that's why I asked them to investigate
corruption and said that they're not
doing a good job of investigating
corruption so Trump keeps putting out
the worst defense there was no quid pro
quo instead of the best defense of
course there was a quid pro quo right
this was Mulvaney right mo vanie
actually tried to put out this defense
he said yes quid pro quos happened in
foreign policy all the time and this
wasn't a bad quid pro quo and people
went nuts and then Trump backtracked it
and now people just keep saying no quid
pro quo it's a dumb defence it's a very
dumb defence there's no reason to focus
in on a bad defense when in actual good
defence and probably a true defense is
actually available meanwhile controversy
has broken out as Republicans are trying
to out the whistleblower now the
Democrats are claiming that the
whistleblower is irrelevant that at this
point we've moved beyond the
whistleblowers complaint there's truth
to that there is I mean the fact is that
we now know what the whistleblower had
to say we have the transcript of the
call the whistleblower complaint really
didn't add anything now I'm being
consistent on this I said that the
whistleblower complaint originally was
less important than the transcript of
the call so but that's how Democrats
that Democrats were like we need the
entire whistleblower complaint or it's
obstruction of justice and a cover-up
like we need to interview the
whistleblower we need his thoughts and
then as soon as it became clear that the
whistleblower was probably a partisan
hack on behalf of Joe Biden then it was
oh we don't need to hear from the
whistleblower anymore so I'm of the
opinion that the whistleblower is
basically irrelevant once the claims of
his complaint are made public but is it
fair for Republicans to point out
Democratic hypocrisy right here yeah
that's totally fair and as far as the
idea that it is a violation of law to to
release the name of the whistleblower no
it isn't whistleblower laws are designed
to prevent the firing of a whistleblower
keeping a whistleblowers name
confidential is usually designed to
prevent their firing in the private
sector
as a private contractor with the United
States government there are regulations
in place that prevent the firing of
whistleblower the Inspector General of a
particular Department is prevented from
speaking the name aloud of the
whistleblower but there's nothing that
prevents Rand Paul from doing it this is
the point that Rand Paul who's been
pushing to out the whistleblower made
yesterday when he was in a 10 attack
with the media actually you see you got
the home coming down you should work on
the back here's the thing is the
whistleblower statute protects the
whistleblower from having his name
revealed by the inspector general even
the New York Times admits that no one
else is under any legal obligation the
other point and you need to be very
careful if you really are interested in
the news is that the whistleblower
actually is a material witness
completely separate from being the
whistleblower because he worked for Joe
Biden he worked for Joe Biden at the
same time hunter Biden is receiving
$50,000 a month
okay so Rand Paul is actually making a
pretty solid case as to why we ought to
know who the whistleblower is which is
why I covered it on the show I mean that
is newsworthy stuff the fact is that if
the situation were reversed and this
were a Republican whistleblower and a
democratic administration we would have
this would have been plastered all over
the front pages of every newspaper
immediately if it turned out that the
person was a partisan hack on behalf of
the Republicans I mean the the media are
so invested in Trump being pushed out of
office they're so invested in hatred of
Trump it's pretty astonishing the best
example today is that the Washington
Post came out with a full Illustrated
Moeller report it's embarrassing I mean
it really is democracy dies in crappy
cartoons they drew all of these pictures
like Paul Manafort and James Comey with
thought bubbles it's absurd they're
publishing a graphic nonfiction book
centered on Special Counsel Robert
Muller's obstruction of justice inquiry
I mean I suppose they couldn't do it on
the Kenneth Starr report cuz then it
just would have been pornography the
malwa report Illustrated is drawn
directly from volume to a special
counsel robert Muller's report of course
they're not going to do it on volume one
because volume one didn't uncover
anything only one was about the Trump
Russia collusion nonsense vol 2 is about
the so called obstruction of justice
according to the Washington Post pumping
this thing the book provides a unique
graphic depiction of the reports most
scrutinized passages and pivotal moments
all contextualized with the posts
original reporting the Mulla report
Illustrated offers a fly-on-the-wall
account of life in the
Whitehouse told through the accounts of
men and women but one time served the
president wow just how magical so we
need a graphic novel of an incredibly
boring report the media media all over
the place so much journalism the
journalism is just getting everywhere
she's just it's everywhere by the way
I'm not sure which is more journalism
the Washington Post printing in this
insane cartoon version of all of this or
a piece by Frank Bruni in the New York
Times called why Donald Trump hates your
dog I'm not kidding because Donald Trump
is constantly saying that people died
like Doug Oreca dick Doug
so apparently according to Frank Bruni
of the newer times from hates dogs and
according to a columnist named gia
Corliss Sean Spicer the former White
House press secretary dances in
militaristic fashion and his body is
dishonest yes I certainly trust the
media with all of this we'll get to more
of I have to read you some appease in
just one second first a thing I like and
then a thing I hate so things I like
today I was on a 16-hour flight from
Israel to the United States over the
weekend that meant that I watched 1
million movies because I mean what else
am I going to do my kids are kicking me
and you're stuck in one place for a very
long time and I got to see a movie that
I really enjoyed I thought it's actually
pretty fantastic it's called in the
heart of the sea it's Ron Howard film
now I tend to think that Ron Howard's
bit of a paint-by-numbers director I've
never seen any of hit anything of his
where I thought this is just
overwhelmingly good but that's fine I
mean it's very straightforward it's sort
of classic cinema it's called in the
heart of the sea with Chris Hemsworth
and Benjamin Walker and and Killian
Murphy who is fantastic and Tom Holland
big big cast Brendan Gleeson and the and
the the movies is about the sort of
source material for Moby Dick it starts
off with with Herman Melville meeting
with the sailor about what happened at
sea on this boat called the Essex and
it's a true story and it is a pretty
astonishing story I mean what didn't
make it into Moby Dick is actually
creepier and more terrifying and what
did make it into Moby Dick it's for
example
after the Essex was it was in fact
stoven by a white whale why giant white
whale that's the basis of Moby Dick but
then the men were basically stranded at
sea for like three months and they had
to resort to as you would think some
pretty awful awful thing
it's it's a good movie it's worth seeing
check it out didn't get the kind of
press that it should have the reviewers
didn't like it because it was too
straightforward because how dare you
make a straightforward film it didn't
have any gender identity politics we
don't know the gender of the whale in
the film but the movie is really good
it's called in the heart of the sea
again wildly underrated by critics and
well worth watching ok time for a quick
thing that I hate so YouTube a lot of
big tech companies are now censoring
content and it's pretty obvious that
they're censoring contents on the basis
of a political persuasion the latest and
creepiest examples that YouTube has now
banned a video from dr. Michelle Rotella
a pediatrician with many years of
experience the executive director of the
American College of pediatricians
there's a video that daily signal
published in 2017 so it's 2 years old it
was up for like two years and now
YouTube has pulled the video the video
has been removed from YouTube in its
place YouTube has displayed the message
the video has been removed for violating
YouTube's policy on hate speech so what
exactly was so hateful what was the hate
speech that this evil doctor had to say
here's what she had to say that got a
ban from YouTube according to most
mainstream medical organizations if you
want to cut off a healthy arm or a
healthy leg you're mentally ill but if
you want to cut off healthy breasts or a
penis you're transgender okay well sorry
that happens to be a true statement okay
now it may be stated in a way that's
very blunt but that happens to be a true
statement okay if you if you according
to most mainstream medical organizations
again this is the text of what she says
according to most mainstream medical
organizations if you want to cut off a
healthy arm or a healthy leg you are
mentally ill if you want to cut off
healthy breasts or penises what she says
you are transgender and they don't
classify transgender as a mental illness
which is what the juxtaposition means
hey this is again I failed to see what
is non factual about this statement now
you may not like that statement you may
think that there is a moral difference
between cutting off your genitals and
cutting off your arm you're gonna have
to explain why that is but the statement
itself is not non factual but apparently
this is now hate speech so according to
the daily signal which is a Heritage
Foundation outlet over the past few
months the daily signal work with
YouTube to try to reach a resolution
ultimately we were told the only way we
could get the video back on YouTube was
to delete the previously mentioned
in other words we get two choices sensor
the doctors words or have no video on
the world's biggest video platform this
should horrify every YouTube user and
anyone who values the importance of a
public square featuring a variety of
perspectives cristela's words are no
doubt controversial says the daily
signal she's no stranger to criticism
neither is the daily signal we welcome
debate but we don't want to be spent but
we don't want to be censored they say we
believe transgender individuals any
individual struggling with gender
identity issues should be treated with
love and respect but we also believe
that on a topic where medical treatments
have such serious ramifications from
infertility to permanent alteration of
body parts it's worth having a robust
fact driven discussion she's making a
point in that sense that maybe not not
popular but remains true there is no
society why push right now to allow
patients suffering from body integrity
identity disorder to amputate limbs
furthermore just this May the World
Health Organization removed
transgenderism from its list of mental
disorders moving it to a section about
sexual health but as of July rotella
sentence amputation of body parts is
different depending on the body parts in
question is apparently so outrageous
YouTube can't even allow it on the
platform that's pretty astonishing like
if YouTube doesn't like it then you know
what there are thousand videos on
YouTube of people trying to explain why
it is more beneficial to people to cut
off their genitals than it is for them
to cut off a different body part I mean
there are lots of videos from the left
about this sort of thing the fact that
YouTube is banning it outright
demonstrates they're putting their their
thumb on the scales when it comes to
contentious social issues that are very
much open for debate and by the way
where the science tends not to favor the
left very much okay we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content so we will
see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Serling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director Pavel why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 bad news fellas Emma Watson is self
partner that's the new PC term for
signal we will examine the left cult of
self-love then Kentucky goes blue kind
of the real election results are more
complicated so don't expect to hear
about that in the mainstream media we
will examine what they mean for 2020
Rand Paul sheds light on impeachment a
new study shows politicized scholarship
makes bad politics and ABC News covers
up its cover-up of the suicide of
Jeffrey Epstein who definitely didn't
kill himself check it out on the Michael
nor show
[Music]